Where's that?
When God is like right off Hollywood between Hollywood and sunset,
I believe.
Awesome.
What time was that?
You want to 10 30 10 30 I hit it 10 30 Oh,
it's only like 150 seats,
man.
So John Pawn at bitches life acoustic out now support.
Everlast go out and buy this shit.
Put your money where your mouth is.
If you fucking dirty.
Beautiful freaks.
All right.
Love you buddy.
Thank you very much for doing this,
man.
So he's a beautiful time.
Pack it up.
Package led me boot again.
Kaino in battling me.
That's a sin.
Never slacked.
Go punk.
You better back up.
Chimed blue.
Who will act up?
Get up,
sign up.
Throw your hand up.
Got The failing.
Jump Up.
[inaudible] Mosley the phone flow.
Someone talks.
You put some in.
Take that punk whole feeling.
Okay.
Answering the chunking.
Got mold downs in this cap.
Set a Duncan donuts shout.
Sure enough,
I got paths from the [inaudible] plus my mom and my pot.
I came to get down can now it's paid now.
Juicy.
Every everybody jump around if apply to jumble around,
everybody jump around.
Jump around from town to town.
They're good,
bad.
It's like I said,
we jump around everybody jumping on now.
Sylvia as like John Mcenroe with you through a step up.
I still smack that whole word to your mom.
I came,
their job mom got more than Enough Bible God psalms and just not by the sun
appetite.
Once that means getting burned.
See cause that guy that Eric's ain't got none.
He come back to bring a shotgun it do you ooh cause the noma due to the death
slipped to me media.
Take it as breath.
Got this.
You go and get your view and swim that shoot the give shoot to fucking get down.
Came the get go in the speed out.
She'll see everybody jumping around.
Everybody jump around in about a jump around everybody jumping around from town
to town compared to bed.
It's like we jump around,
everybody jump around.
Um,
the cream of the crop arise to the top.
I never use because of pagans cap dedicated some Neda like on those sorts of
Nicu channel play me like as if my name was Sega Dang.
Like no punk bitch used to one style.
I might switch it up around,
plug buck you down without your hand.
Then you,
Dan from commonly gets Ya.
Commonly gives Ya [inaudible] outlets.
Yeah.
That came to get out game.
They get down,
get out.
You'll see everybody jumping around in the paddock jumble.
Ever bought a jumper.
You have about a jumble around from town to town,
from bed to bed.
It's like I said with jumbo.
Everybody jump on now.
That was beautiful.
Can I have everybody?
Raga Joan,
you will Damon my bones.
Yeah.
It's a vampire in your life.
Find the light sucking situation that you're afraid to kill.
And the reason I say vampires because vampire is only go where they're invited.
And generally the situation that you're in,
you invited it in,
you invited this thing into your life and now.